the new Skyfall trailer was just
released and as you guys may or may not
know Casino Royale is actually one of my
all-time favorite movies for me Casino
Royale is so good that when I watch it I
forget I'm watching a Bond movie it's
just like its own complete film so I'm
really excited for a Skyfall when I
heard the new trailer was released I was
like yeah yes I checked it out and I
want to talk to you guys about it I love
this trailer this trailer is what I
wanted it to be this tone is what I
wanted it to be I am so excited for this
movie you see Daniel Craig is bond he's
sitting there as being questioned by
somebody and it's different though like
it's almost like a therapist session or
something it's like he's saying words
and the first thing that pops into bonds
head he's supposed to say you hear him
say the word Skyfall and immediately
that gets Vaughn's attention something
in bonds past is extremely affected by
that word sky falling that just oh I
just I really want to see this movie
when I found out that Sam Mendes was
gonna be directing this movie you know
he made movies like American Beauty it
Road to Perdition I was extremely
excited because that's such a different
choice you know his films are
beautifully shot they all look fantastic
and when I heard that a director that
isn't as common with this type of genre
is gonna come on and make this movie
that really pumped me up and this
trailer looks immaculate I mean these
shots look fantastic there's something
about the way this movie looks that
makes it seem like it is not going to be
your typical action movie it's not gonna
be your typical Bond movie it's not
gonna be your typical anything now after
this opening we get a lot of cool action
shots you know it's just a teaser it's
not like a theatrical trailer it gives
you a little bit of what's going on you
know it kind of gives you a taste but
what I really like is just you get an
idea of the tone this film is going for
and it seems very dark and serious when
the last shot you see is a silhouetted
man walking away from something that's
boarding I'm assuming that's Harvey of
our team who plays the villain in this
movie and if you've seen No Country for
Old Men you know that guy can play a
villain so well man this trailer which
is everything I wanted I was so happy
with this trailer it was only a minute
and 23 seconds or something but it just
really really satisfied me I love the
look of the movie the shots look
masterful can't wait to see what's going
on in this film I'm intrigued by the
idea of this story that seems like it's
taking the same route that Casino Royale
took where it's not your typical Bond
movie you know it's different because
with Casino Royale you know you walk
into that movie
that points like yeah I can inspect
everything that's gonna be in a Bond
movies gonna ask for the martinis shaken
not stirred you know but all these
gadgets a big scene with Q none of that
happened in that movie flip the tropes
of Bob's upside down and I really hope
that Skyfall does that too it looks like
that's going to I'm I'm pumped for this
movie man what do you guys think this
guy bald the trailer let me know what
you think below when Skyfall actually
comes out I'm gonna do a review for
Casino Royale because I have so much to
say about that movie such a good movie
this Tuesday I'm gonna be seeing men in
black 3 on Thursday I'm seeing chernobyl
Diaries and somewhere in between there
I'm gonna review lethal weapon for you
guys because I just watched that movie
that is a really great classic action
movie and I realized I have never once
talked about it I need to so if someone
were tweeting that maybe reviewing that
movie - there's always guys if you like
this review you can subscribe to my
channel and get stuff mine eyes some men
are coming to kill us we're gonna kill
em fast